- Alright, y'all know I
always like to close an hour
with something I hope will
bring extra joy in your day.
This is what I'm liking.
(jazz music)
(audience clapping)
Sadly, the war in
Ukraine is still going on
and it's absolutely
devastating and heartbreaking
but one New Yorker is
giving Ukrainian kids
the chance to just be kids
through the magic of baseball.
Jordan Baltimore runs
a baseball program here
in the city, and he's also
created a not-for-profit
that makes the sport accessible
in the most underserved parts of New York.
Recently, he took a few of his players
to Poland to teach
displaced Ukrainian orphans
the beloved all American sport
and the impacts have proven to
be long lasting for everyone.
We have Jordan with us now.
(crowd cheering and clapping)
Hi Jordan.
So tell us about this trip to Poland.
- So when the war began, uh,
we immediately mobilized the nonprofit
and began raising money for and donating
to organizations on the
ground in Warsaw, in Ukraine.
And I felt like we needed to do more.
I knew we needed to do more.
And one of the moms in
our program introduced us
to the SOK foundation over in Warsaw
and they're doing an incredible
job of feeding and caring
for orphans who have
come over from Ukraine.
Um 650 of them are now in one orphanage
on the outskirts of Warsaw.
And that conversation
with SOK foundation led
to a trip, four days six children
that came with me and
their families joined us.
- Wow.
- We went there,
we thought we were going
to be teaching baseball.
We ended up cooking,
cleaning, serving food
to thousands of refugees
in and around Warsaw.
And then we spent two
days teaching baseball too
and playing baseball
with hundreds of
Ukrainian orphan refugees.
And if you want to put
things in perspective,
walk into an orphanage
where you see 650 children
with no parents.
And it meant so much to us.
It was emotionally overwhelming.
Uh, the next day we were on
the baseball field with them
teaching how to run the bases.
- Yeah.
- Throwing catch,
- Hit a baseball, and it all culminated
in the American school of
Warsaw with a baseball game.
- That's amazing.
- And-
Well, since then, we've raised
$50,000 and we've donated
to the SOK foundation there
and we're now back in touch
with the children and planning what's next
and when we're going back.
- It's so cool what you're doing,
I'm liking your post right now, Jordan.
(doorbell ringing)
(audience clapping)
- And that's not all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot, pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show,
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you, sir.
And so they're gonna be writing
a check to Sharing Empire
for a thousand dollars just to help out.
(audience clapping and cheering)
Thank you for what you're
doing, it's so cool.
So very cool.
(audience cheering and clapping)
That's not all.
Pilot, America's number one pen
is partnering with
America's number one team
and they're giving
everyone in the audience
and all of our guests four tickets
to a 2022 New York Yankees
regular season game.
(audience cheering and clapping)